General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a TR
retre I'm not built like other
mens in their masses
move along now those in power only see
me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds at plot destruction if
you look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you'll always
want it Sorcerer of death
Construction
I must warn you I will not lead a second
of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
head
that's is where the's
burning you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without this
[Music]
Veron whose country are we
in
a
mine